voilà je vous le disais dans les titres
huit communes des yvelines ont fait le
choix de changer de rythme scolaire et
donc de passer aux quatre jours et demi
par semaine dès le mois de septembre
vont avoir tout de suite un tableau qui
récapitule justement ces communes des
yvelines est la ville la plus importante
du département à faire ce choix que l'on
découvre ces fameux huit villes des
yvelines ces trappes suivre les mureaux
et poissy alors est ce courageux est ce
compliqué en tout cas on va en parler
avec nos invités et je voudrais aussi
présenter un autre et un autre schéma
puisque le processus est temps a été
enclenchée et le 31 mai les
représentants de l'éducation nationale a
validé la nouvelle organisation à
trappes et voilà cette nouvelle
organisation qu'on va pour que les
parents d'élèves vont pouvoir découvrir
à partir de septembre
et donc pour en parler autour de cette
table bonsoir à vous messieurs bonsoir
guy malandain maire de trappes
bonsoir nicolas hardy vous êtes
représentant des parents d'élèves et
pertes en mesure bonsoir représentants
des enseignants
alors guy malandain comme je l'aï dit
rap c'est l'avis de la plus importante
des yvelines à avoir choisi de changer
de rythme scolaire dès septembre 2013
pourquoi ce choix
aussi vite parce qu'il ya que huit ans
dans le département où suis vite aussi
vite taillé comme une commune sur 262
qu'on les émotions qu'elle est le qu'il
est la problématique de fond après tout
le reste est dérisoire quel est le
problème de fond c'est est-ce que quatre
journées une bichi d'école pour les
enfants c'est mieux que 4 pour les
enfants attrapent ses rayons les enfants
4250 élèves 196 classe 36 écoles et aux
tic donc extrêmement important pour nous
l'essentiel
et donc on s'est posé la question voilà
avec 2013 est ce que cela me fait
presque le fond c'est qu'a durés demi
seniors toutes les personnes qu'on a
entendu tout ce que moi j'ai pu lire
mais ça suffit pas qu'on dit mais oui
c'est mieux c'est
ce n'est pas bien d'avoir concentré aux
tendres sur quatre jours parce que tout
moment où ou où ce débat a été tranché
est-ce qu'on commence plus tard ou
est-ce qu'on commence maintenant
pas de questions par rapport à notre
responsabilité je ne suis pas
responsable de les associations et de
tout ça je suis responsable de comment
apporter un plus
comment apporter un mieux comment
garantir davantage autant que faire se
peut à l'avenir de 4250 enfance est très
importante donc il n'y a aucune raison
d'attendre partir de ce moment là le
travail a commencé
vite vite et bien
avec beaucoup de parents avec des
enseignants avec les actions de parents
d'élèves qui avaient voté pour après
l'été puis la côte est complexé salle
n'a aucun cas au moins ok rien
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation où les horaires ont été
approuvés par l'inspecteur d'académie la
décision de l'ancien de lui tresser mais
rejet absolu ma responsabilité
l'inspecteur d'académie a assumé la
sienne en acceptant les horaires sont
proposés qui avait été adoptée par un
comité de politesse à l'unanimité je
n'ai pas vu de voix contre se lever et
puis maintenant nous mettons nous
mettons en place ce qui nous regarde en
tant que ville c'est à dire les
activités sperry colère le matin le midi
et le soir
léger mieux j'ai mieux vous dire je vais
au bout parce qu'après ça m'intéresse
que ce qui est en train de se préparer
avec des enseignants avec les services
de la ville avec un nombre important
l'association avec des entreprises qui
ont des choses à faire découvrir aux
enfants va noblesse ou le bon terme un
cave a animé les temps périscolaires
dont dont nous sommes responsables
on ouvre et j'en termine par là pour
vous donner un exemple on y consacre un
million d'euros or les subventions de
l'état si elles viennent verra bien ça
c'est autre chose et on ouvre 36
chantier 36 chantier d'adaptation des
écoles pour avoir ce que nous ont
recommandé les experts les temps de
repos les temps l'étendue d'un choix
personnel de telle ou de telle ou telle
activité c'est donc pour nous un
engagement vraiment extrêmement
important on a ouvert les informations
aux habitants en deux semaines on et 400
familles qui sont devenus est comme moi
je descends trois fois par jour voire on
va mener à la parole à bertrand mesure
pour les enseignants un connard 10 pour
les parents d'élèves est ce que vous
vous êtes satisfait de cette
réorganisation des rythmes scolaires
écoutez je crois que sur l'ardente
obligation d'en parler monsieur le maire
de d'avoir des rythmes scolaires adaptés
aux enfants tout le monde est d'accord
d'ailleurs c'était le propos des
ateliers quatre jours et demi c'est tout
à fait simplement pourrait se poser la
question puisque c'est une compétence de
la municipalité pourquoi ça n'a pas été
fait avant si c'était une aussi
importante obligations alors on a
l'impression qu'il ya un effet d'aubaine
derrière tout ça et que nous ce qu'on
souhaitait c'est que comme le ministre
l'avait proposé c'est que s'engage un
processus de coopération entre
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'école et
malheureusement il n'y a eu que quelques
discussions au travers de quelques
ateliers très formaté et que à chaque
fois que nous en tout cas en tant
qu'enseignant nous avons demandé à
rentrer dans un vrai processus qui ne
concernait pas les quatre jours et demi
mais qui concernait la mise en oeuvre au
quotidien
ç'a toujours été un refus et donc c'est
ce qui est à bord et sur l'organisation
qui est présenté sur l'organisation
crise scolaire à 8h50 même
l'organisation qui est présente et si
vous voulez si on regarde les autres
projets des communes des yvelines
c'est le projet je dirais le plus
exotique parce que il n'ya pas un
équilibre entre les deux parties de la
semaine on a des horaires qui sont peu
pratiques à retenir à part le vendre
parce que le vendredi est un peu plus
tôt à le vendredi par exemple les
enfants sortent plutôt si on regarde pas
un plus le seul projet d'une commune
équivalente comme les mureaux le lundi
et le mardi
il ya des offres qui peuvent être
différents et le jeudi et vendredi mais
il ya un équilibre entre les deux
parties de la semaine bon il est plein
de petites choses comme ça l'heure
d'arrivée des enfants 8h50
pourquoi pas 9h ou enfin bon on a
beaucoup de sens quand c'était ce choix
justement horaires parce que c'est vrai
que 8h50 le matin 16h20 en fin de
journée 15h55 le vendredi c'est vrai que
c est ce qu une horaire mais franchement
pourquoi 8h et papa 750 ce n'est pas le
fonds de fonds doit faire les horaires
ils ont été adoptées au cours de quatre
ateliers de travail pas encadré du tout
jeune et qui voulait disait disait ce
qu'il avait à dire qu'il voulait sauf
que sauf que moi j'attends toujours qui
est des gens qui viennent voilà ceux qui
rouspètent le plus c'est ce truc qui
sont pas venus et pourquoi pas ses
oreilles ils ont ils ont personnellement
je suis venu l'avion assez simple c'est
que justement le sujet qu'il y avait
dans ses ateliers portait sur
l'opportunité d'améliorer les rythmes
scolaires pour les enfants ce donc
personne ne doutait par contre sur
l'opportunité de le faire en 2013 ou en
ça n'était pas à l'ordre du jour sur la
façon dont les choses allaient se
ménager ce n'était pas l'heure du jour
on voit par ailleurs dans le bulletin
municipal figurait que on a fait venir
le professeur montagnier pour sa peau
s'est alors que des cantines où le
niveau sonore est diminué c'est
favorable aux enfants jeux
je peux dire que tous les enseignants de
trappes et je pense tous les parents
d'élèves pouvez le dire monsieur le
maire bien avant de faire venir monsieur
montanier niveau lardy alors vous
pourrez pas vous représenter un regard
des réponses précises et juste la fcpe a
voté favorablement pour le changement
l'exception à l'exception de certains
parents d'élèves 10 d'ici dans les
classes voilà donc effectivement
division j'ai imposé mon préparant
l'association est affiliée à junas peut
se les parents sans étiquette et donc
effectivement les parents excédés et
décidant un petit peu déçus de leur de
leur conseil local monsieur le maire
vous avez là vous m'avez gentiment
attaque effectivement oui j'ai voté et
je me suis prononcée pour ce que j'avais
estimé lors du dernier comité technique
comme étant le projet le moins mauvais
coup de théâtre enfin en cause comité
technique la ville nous présente nous
propose trois scénarios
les trois commençant à 9 heures sauf un
avec un lundi commencé une demi heure
plus tard nos effectivement comité
technique août chacun devait apporter
ses propositions on s'est retrouvés face
à face à une entité qui nous a va dire
les mots imposés 6 3 ces trois schémas
effectivement on a réussi à faire des on
a réussi à faire des propositions des
petits changements coup théâtre deux
jours deux jours avant le comité de
pilotage qui devait valider ce projet on
a deux jours avant on nous appelle au
téléphone en disant à stop on a un
dernier projet avec le rappel des
horaires pour la pause méridienne décalé
pour les élémentaires et les maternelles
art chose que la fcpe était en joie
d'apprendre départ je me suis proposé de
lui présenter une
et j'ai bien fini mais je me suis
proposé je me suis prononcé pour le
moins mauvais effectivement l'une a
permis aujourd'hui votre regard sur ce
qui est proposé ce qui est proposé
on a fait on a résumé vous c'est en a
fait des propositions
j'y viens on a fait des propositions
qu'on a qu'on vous a qu'on a
effectivement pour être présenté au
conseil municipal du 22 avril
j'avais effectivement on avait notre
association arômes oblige on a regardé
un petit peu ce qu'il faisait et
notamment de l'éducation nationale vous
regardez les quatre projets de
l'éducation nationale qui était pas trop
mauvais on sait une hausse est basée sur
le 4e loisir qu'est ce que vous
souhaiteriez j'y arrive effectivement
qu'il restait sur dix huit heures 30
8h30 et qui restait sur une héparine et
quitté la ville depuis est victime en a
trop changé ses horaires on était sur du
neuf heures moi je que je dénonce
effectivement ces combats on va même et
on va amener les élèves à se mettre en
place dans la phase dans la phase où ils
sont enfin dans la période qui sont plus
en phase d'être content d'être concentré
donc enfin compte le temps de se mettre
en place
elvire pendant 10 minutes ils vont
d'abord ils vont perdre ce temps de
concentration
après bon les quelques jours et nuits
mais effectivement moi je reviens pas
dessus parce que en 2008 j'ai me
positionner pour les qu'on regarde les
neuf demi journées donc là de ce côté là
il n'y a pas de changement
mais lorsqu'elle proposez vous dire ce
qui est proposé scellés sur geste je
fais horaire ouais les horaires où
effectivement on est satisfait je suis
satisfait après 60 % soit 10 % 30 %
là je veux dire je vais être satisfait a
1 1 entre 45 45 45
petite pause en aveyron va faire déjà
une petite pause en cette rentrée on va
aller dans les routes de trappes puisque
ce matin nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des trappistes pour leur
demander justement leur avis sur ce
changement de rythme scolaire dans la
commune on les écoute le changement du
rythme scolaire est nécessaire pour les
enfants ça c'est une certitude
seulement je pense qu'il aurait mieux
valu prendre un peu plus leur lait coûte
les parents et les enseignants et
attendre je pense la rentrée 2014
parce que refaire école le mercredi
matin pour deux heures et demie c'est
pas franchement c'est pas bien le rythme
à quatre jours je trouve c'est pas mal
même si c'est un peu contraignant pour
les parents qui doivent le dire géré par
rapport à leur planning de travail ce
qui a toute une organisation rapport la
garde des enfants
c'est dommage d'en lever mercredi ça
faisait une coupure pour les enfants
salsa les aider à être un petit peu plus
en forme
les enfants ne devraient pas avoir école
le mercredi n'est un samedi ils sont
déjà toute la semaine pour moi je trouve
ca c je trouve ça nul pense qu'en
définitive dans la société ou lacanau
vie vous avez en france je ne sais
combien de communes vous avez les trois
quarts qui n'ont pas les appliquer un
car il va peut-être l'appliquer moi
j'estime que chaque ministre qui
arrivent il veut en définitif poser son
empreinte et dire voilà j'ai fait une
loi elle vaut ce qu'elle vaut elle vaut
peut-être rien mais je la fais quand
même
voilà ce que je pense